Let's wrap up our hands-on exercise with the final steps of the Mesh to Metahuman workflow.
So let's dive back into Unreal Engine.
After running the Metahuman Identity Solve, if the tracking markers still need to be adjusted,
or you wish to add additional markers to refine certain areas, such as the eyes and ears,
you can now enable additional tracking markers.
In the top right over here, we can see additional tracking options that we can enable.
Some tracking curves may already be set to visible, and others may be disabled.
If you hover your mouse over the icon next to the tracker name, an image of what portion
of the face that tracker is assigned to will appear, which can be helpful.
If for example we want to add tracking markers to the left and right eye crease, we can go
here to make the left eye crease visible, then select this to enable the curve to be
used for the solve.
Let's repeat these steps for the other eye crease.
Now go to the tracking markers of the right eye to start adjusting the eye crease tracking
marker positions.
I'm going to select this tracking curve and move it over the eye crease, and then I will
start to reposition each individual tracking marker.
Moving over to the left eye, I'm going to move the tracking curve, but this time I will
deselect each tracking marker one by one.
Now if you wish to track the ears, we can add another frame by going here and clicking
on the plus sign.
I'm going to rotate the camera so that we can see the left ear.
And now I will go to the top right over here, and I'm going to select the first ear and
drop this down.
I will change the visibility for each tracking curve, and this will automatically set these
tracking curves to active.
Just make sure with this frame selected, go to the neutral pose details panel on the
left over here, and in the frame promotion panel, uncheck used to solve for this additional
frame.
We do this so that only one frame is used for the identity solve.
I'm going to delete this frame now.
Once you are finished adding additional tracking curves and adjusting their positions, go back
to the toolbar and run the metahuman identity solve again.
You can keep running the metahuman identity solve and continue to adjust tracking marker
positions or adding new tracking curves until you are happy with the results.
Use the viewport toolbar to continue to inspect your mesh.
I can see when using the overlay option that the eye creases have assisted in getting a
better solve and I am happy with the results.
Once you have a ballpark approximation of what you want to achieve, the final step here
is to auto-rig the metahuman identity.
Go to the main toolbar, then go to mesh to metahuman and drop this down.
You can choose whether you want to auto-rig the skeletal mesh only, which will create
an auto-rigged version with the embedded DNA added to the Unreal Engine project, or you
can select skeletal mesh and full metahuman.
Once selected, you may be prompted to sign in with your Epic Games account.
This will generate a skeletal mesh with embedded DNA to the project and a full metahuman will
appear in the metahuman creator for further editing.
This process may take a few moments to complete.
A pop-up will appear letting us know that a skeletal mesh with embedded DNA is now available
in our content browser and a metahuman is also available in the metahuman creator.
We can now leave this metahuman identity asset window and go back to our main viewport.
I'm going to save everything and in the content browser, there will be the skeletal
mesh of the metahuman identity.
The final step of this workflow is to go to the metahuman creator and further customize
our metahuman.
In the main viewport, go to the get content panel and select Quixel Bridge.
Go to the Quixel Bridge menu on the left and in the my metahumans option, you will be able
to locate and select your newly created metahuman identity.
With the metahuman identity selected, we can go here on the right to start the metahuman
creator.
Now, as we wait for the metahuman creator browser to load, let's review the steps we
just completed.
Once you have tracked a neutral pose and run the metahuman identity solve, additional markers
can be added.
In the top right window, you can see all of the tracking markers that are available.
Some of them by default will be visible and used for the initial metahuman identity solve.
If you hover over the icon located next to a curve, an image of what portion of the face
that tracker is assigned to will appear.
You can change a tracking curve to visible and also change it to active so that it is
used for the solve.
Then you can continue rerunning the metahuman identity solve and adjusting or adding more
tracking curves until you are happy with the results.
The next step is to finalize your metahuman identity.
In the main toolbar, go to the mesh to metahuman dropdown and select auto rig metahuman identity
and full metahuman so that you can make further adjustments to it in the metahuman creator.
When you run the auto rig and full metahuman option, a skeletal mesh and embedded DNA will
be added to your project and a placeholder for your metahuman identity will become available
in the metahuman creator.
Now, let's wrap things up with the final steps of this workflow inside of the metahuman
creator.
Now that the metahuman creator browser has loaded, we can see our metahuman in the My
Metahumans gallery.
With this already selected, I am going to go down here and select edit selected.
I am going to stop the animation and I want to toggle off the hotkeys.
In the properties and attributes, we can see the custom mesh panel has become available.
I want to change the camera view to focus on the face for this.
Now this is unique to metahumans created with the mesh to metahuman workflow.
This slider allows you to adjust the overall region influence which blends the delta in
volume between your input and a template metahuman.
I will bring the face a bit closer.
Over here in this panel, you can select specific regions of the face and then move the slider
to increase or decrease the region influence for this specific area.
This is especially helpful if you find problematic areas.
If I select the eyes for instance and start to move the slider, we can see how even though
the change is minor, this can be useful if your custom character's eyeballs and eyelid
might be intersecting.
And you may find it helpful to use this on the mouth area to blend a bit of the template
mesh in cases where perhaps the teeth and lips may be intersecting.
In order to use the blend, sculpt and move tools, you can select enable editing.
It might be helpful to select duplicate and unlock so that you always have a copy of the
original in the event you want to revert back to it.
Now before we start making any modifications, it may be helpful to view your character with
skin textures applied by going to the skin control.
Select assign skin color to apply a skin texture.
You will notice that the template mesh texture is assigned as the texture we used previously
will not transfer over.
Now you can see your newly created metahuman character come to life by using the animation
toolbar and continue inspecting and refining your character.
Now that we have gone over some of the options inside of the metahuman creator that are unique
to the mesh to metahuman workflow, let's wrap up this section of our course by reviewing
the steps we just completed.
The last step of the mesh to metahuman workflow is to inspect the metahuman identity inside
of the metahuman creator.
An option that is unique to this workflow is the region influence which allows you to
blend either the entire face of your input with the template metahuman or to adjust the
region influence for specific areas of the face.
This option is especially helpful if you have problematic areas such as the eyes and eyelids
intersecting or to adjust certain areas of the mouth.
You can use the blend sculpt and move tools by enabling editing.
You will be prompted to duplicate and unlock the metahuman so that you have a backup of
your original or to just use the original to make further adjustments.
The original albedo texture associated with your 3D model will be replaced by the template
mesh texture so you can assign a skin texture in the skin tab.
You can apply animations to your metahuman using the animation toolbar and again this
will be helpful in spotting problematic areas or to be able to view any customizations you
make as you continue to refine your character.
And this brings us to the end of this section of our course.
In the next section we will take a look at how to bring a metahuman into Unreal Engine
and also go over some best practices for working with it in your project.